when you were on
your daily Vlog grind and even now the
videos that you put up I just feel like
you've represented the magic of the city
so well I also felt like a Judas
when covet happened that I wasn't here
New York City on during that time and
you like I know what the reality of
the city was like then and I had a
unique ability to communicate that yeah
like I could have used my I would have
used every Power every Outlet I had to
say no no no no everything you're saying
is a lie do you wanna know what
this city is go to any subway station
any subway station in all five boroughs
push your stroller up to the
stairs Watch What Happens yeah you will
last one still last one second
in someone yeah whether it's like some
300 pound homeless guy some old
lady someone's gonna pick up that stroll
yeah I don't want to leave this like it
doesn't get better than this this city
it is my muse on a level that's like
like I fall asleep thinking about this